the quality of education has plummeted
in this country there's a newly released
video
of a teacher from the san marco unified
school district this is in california
you'll be shocked to hear
yelling at her students over distance
learning
and other issues this was this was
posted to facebook apparently it's a
common
occurrence take a listen to what your
children are being taught in the virtual
classroom
my question is in this case where is the
white student because because we need
all right
if your parent wants to talk to me
about their profession and their opinion
on their profession
i would love to hear that i know very
little about anything
else in the world other than education
okay
however if your parent wants to come
talk to me
about how i'm not doing a good enough
job
in distance learning based on what you
need as an individual
just dare them to come at me because i'm
so
sick to my stomach of parents
trying to tell educators how to do their
job i have never once gone to a doctor's
appointment
and tried to tell my medical health
provider how to treat me
you know why because i know nothing
about that i didn't get my degree in
medicine
i know nothing about that i know very
little about anything in the world
that those are true statements i would
suspect not the sort of thing you want
to hear your kid's teacher say
look i know very little about anything
in the world
other than education
you see the problem right education
is an instrument to convey
all all that other knowledge you know
about everything in the world
to a student right you're supposed to
know a lot of things
like you know dates and battles
and the books instead you're supposed to
know all that
and then education is the process
by which you convey all of that
knowledge which this woman admits she
doesn't have
to a student which is why she doesn't do
it very well she also doesn't seem to be
particularly talented
at the education part of it right if
you're screaming at students
and you're parroting a typical left-wing
racialist line
that we need to have racial grievance
groups and racial unions
for every racial group except for white
people the awful terrible white people
and then to to make this point about
education that is so elementary but she
just doesn't understand it which is she
says
your parents have no role in your
education
i crazy ignorant lady i
am going to be your educator i who
haven't cultivated my upper
will and intellect i who am given away
to wrath
and invective i will educate you and how
dare your parents suggest they have any
say in it but of course
the family is the first place that
education happens
i'm not just talking about for
homeschoolers or people who have some
very
solid view of the world i'm saying for
everybody the best lessons you ever
learned in your life
really the enduring lessons that you
learned maybe some
you learned in school i learned some
great lessons in school
but really those enduring lessons that
have really shaped my life
beyond even the technical aspects of
learning how to write learning how to
read history
the ones that really shape how you are
educated meaning the whole person the
way you are raised up where did you
learn those you learn those at home
of course and
parents ought to have some say in their
child's education
this was one of the premises of william
f buckley jr's famous book that launched
the post-war conservative movement
god and man at yale that parents
trustees
people outside of the education system
ought to exert power on that education
system
is that going to be a cultural power or
political power we're talking about a
public school here
so it would seem that you got it it's a
little bit of both isn't it
certainly whatever parents or are living
in the school district
ought to exert a lot of political power
to make sure
that their students aren't being
educated by people like this crazy lady
how are the teachers getting away with
it the teachers are getting away with
this sort of thing
because of of the lockdowns because
they're they're now they get to teach
from distance learning
and they have a lock on these kids
they've clearly gone a little bit
kookier than usual even
and they're just sitting in their homes
saying and spatting off on whatever they
want
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you